hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about receding gums and vitamin C
receding gums is a vitamin C deficiency
so let's talk about that vitamin C has a
lot to do with protein building
specifically collagen and when you lose
the collagen your gums start to recede
and there's too much tooth and there's
not enough gum if you look at the
arteries for example and you get a
little lesion or a leaky space between
the little cells
that's a vitamin C deficiency because
you're losing the collagen Junction so
vitamin C helps those cellular junctions
become really really tight in your
intestines you need vitamin C to keep
the the junctions tight prevent leaky
gut leaky gut is normally a vitamin C
deficiency okay
so bacteria for example do they're a
negative effect through proteolytic
enzymes basically those are enzymes to
break down proteins vitamin C counters
the effect of the proteolytic enzymes so
basically that's why when you're sick
and you take vitamin C you get better
because they reduce the toxic effect
from bacteria in fact the white blood
cell which is your immune cell has more
vitamin C carries more vitamin C than
any other cell in the body because it
needs this vitamin C to protect you so
when you brush your teeth in it and you
bleed easily that is a vitamin C
deficiency they call that scurvy there's
many other symptoms with vitamin C
deficiencies but receding gums is a very
common symptom so how do you become
vitamin C deficient
number one you can have high levels of
insulin like you have insulin resistance
you're pre-diabetic or you're an actual
diabetic or you consume a lot of junk
food that will do it right there or it
could be that you're consuming sulfa
drugs which are antibiotics certain
antibiotics or you're just not consuming
enough vitamin C from your food so
sauerkraut has the most vitamin C
fermented vegetables vegetables in
general and also bell peppers one of my
favorite vegetables is the bell pepper
so I get mine from the farmers market
because they're smaller
they're way more nutritious and they
actually taste really good so I'll
consume like five ideas in one fitting
so a couple of benefits of vitamin C it
also will help you reduce the toxic
effect of hyperthyroidism it will also
help reduce histamine that's why it's
great for the common cold there's the
sinus issues when you're coughing when
you have allergies vitamin C is really
really helpful also vitamin C will
increase the oxygen in your body so if
you're going up a flight of stairs and
you're going to breath easily you need
vitamin C so just make sure you don't
consume vitamin C from a pill get it
from food because most vitamin C
supplements are synthetic alright thanks
for watching hi guys hey listen I
created a pretty amazing evaluation quiz
down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you report